let's get right into it normally i would
waste a ton of time at the top of the
show
talking about the show but we actually
have too much show today so let's just
get right into it
um i'm a little worried that there are
too many people on the left who were not
seriously looking at joe biden's
proposals and platform particularly
his economic proposals not looking at
them seriously enough
and giving credit where credit is due
for what yes would be the most
progressive economic platform of an
american president
in decades and decades and i would argue
even going beyond
the high marginal tax rates of
eisenhower's administration and i'll
explain why in a little bit
there's a very good piece in marketwatch
called liberals aren't giving joe biden
credit
for a radical tax plan that goes after
the indolent rich the article is by nick
buffy we're linking to it on youtube i
encourage you to read it
and the article accurately points out as
i've been pointing out for
months that there is a contingent of the
left that is branding joe biden as sort
of like the ultimate centrist
the epitome of the um
uh democratic candidate who is
almost a republican or would have been a
republican in times past
i think that that could not be further
from the truth now i've said
this phrase it would be the most
progressive economic platform in modern
political history and there were people
writing me saying
david it's meaningless because it's
2020.
what how is that meaningless it's
accurate okay you can say
times have changed and our expectations
have moved to the left and that's a good
thing
and therefore it is also a good thing if
our
elected officials are following the
movement of the country
politically and the concern for me is
coming partially from i think that there
are some on the left who are just
ideologically blinded
and then there are others who just
aren't looking at the proposals so
let's focus in on the tax proposals that
joe biden has
separate yourself from ideology
and separate yourself from what would be
the perfect
and analyze what is joe biden's platform
joe biden
would raise the corporate profit tax and
establish
what is effectively a minimum tax for
corporations similar to the alternative
minimum tax that people have had
since individuals have had since 1969.
that
is radical in a context where both
parties have allowed the zero
tax dollar status quo of corporations to
perpetuate itself
joe biden would eliminate deductions for
high-income earners
joe biden would repeal most of the trump
tax cuts and
increase taxes on fossil fuel emissions
so uh joe biden would uncap
starting at four hundred thousand
dollars the twelve
percent tax uh for social security
that is absolutely massive i actually
don't think for a moment i'm going to
imagine
it's not that people don't care it's
that people don't understand the
magnitude of that
you would see a ceo who earns 10 million
dollars a year
go from paying a 0.2 percent effective
social security tax to a 12 percent
effective social security tax that is a
massively radical proposal which you
will see
all sorts of people uh fight tooth and
nail to prevent
from becoming a reality and then joe
biden would take those revenues
and reinvest them in raising social
security benefits for the poor
that's exactly the type of policy that a
bernie sanders type
would put in place there are hundreds of
thousands of seniors who would be
immediately pulled out of poverty
as a result of that policy without it
costing the middle class
a penny some say a dime i say a penny
as we know capital gains is something
that allows
the super rich who don't work to pay
less as an effective tax rate than many
people who do work
capital gains long-term capital gains
taxed at a far
lower rate than earned income for the
rich
joe biden has proposed eliminating that
lower capital gains rate on dividends
and
long-term capital gains for everybody
making above
a million dollars per year if you
combine that
with raising the top tax rate back to
close to 40 percent
that is a combination of proposals from
joe biden
which would nearly double the average
tax rate for non-working
millionaires the tax policy center has
analyzed this proposal
and has found that three-quarters of joe
biden's tax increases
would fall on the one percent on the top
one percent
and a lot of that remaining 25 would
fall
on the top two to four percent this is
serious stuff
this is serious radical stuff the people
that then come in and say well he'll
never get it done
but hold on that that's not just joe
biden every president has trouble
getting done
what they want to do and you would have
to apply that exact same standard that
exact same logic that exact same caveat
to bernie sanders you can say well it's
not
left enough okay but say that and
recognize
that it would be the most progressive
economic policy
for a sitting president for a long long
time there will be people who come in
and say
but the top marginal tax rate was up in
the 90s during dwight d
eisenhower's presidency yes but the
amount of loopholes available at that
time and remember
the alternative minimum tax was not put
in place until 1969.
so prior to that even with these high
sticker tax rates under eisenhower
the very rich were rarely paying
anything close to that because of the
amount of loopholes and because of the
lack of
what's called the alternative minimum
tax so
you can critique joe biden in saying he
doesn't go far enough for example joe
biden wants to
reinstate some of those state and local
tax deductions
that donald trump got rid of there is no
doubt
that there are sort of medium wealthy
and super wealthy people in blue states
that lost some significant deductions
when trump
capped state and local tax deductions
and yes
both the democratic and republican party
are beholden to donors
and that is something joe biden wants to
reinstate but
contrast it with the magnitude of the
other things that he's proposing to do
so criticize joe biden for not going far
enough
contextualize that we have two very
corporate parties that control
politics in this country do all of that
stuff but
let's not be blind because of ideology
or laziness or lack of curiosity
these are some pretty radical proposals
here and whether
or not joe biden can get it done that's
a different question
trump hasn't gotten done the things he
promised bernie would not be able to get
done the things he wanted to do
elizabeth warren would have had i mean i
don't know how you pass a wealth tax i
really don't
but we have to judge by what the
platforms are
and this is very serious stuff in in any
case
you are going to have no opportunity
if donald trump gets another four years
this is not
you know the lesser of two evils
there is clearly a better option here
and it is not a small margin
it is a dramatic margin between what
donald trump wants to do and has done on
taxes
and what joe biden his proposal
proposing just the facts my friends just
the facts
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book on your
way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time
to do all the reading you want to do or
if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video